"Beauty is a curse," Psyche thought
as she looked over the cliff's edge
where she'd been abandoned by her father.
She'd been born with the physical
perfection so complete
that she was worshipped as a new
incarnation of Venus, the goddess of love.
But real-life human lovers were
too intimidated even to approach her.
When her father asked for guidance
from the Oracle of Apollo,
the god of light, reason, and prophecy.
He was told to abandon his daughter
on a rocky crag
where she would marry a cruel
and savage serpent-like winged evil.
Alone on the crag, Psyche felt
Zephyr the West Wind
gently lifting her into the air.
It set her down before a palace.
"You are home," she heard
an unseen voice say.
"Your husband awaits you
in the bedroom, if you dare to meet him."
She was brave enough, Psyche told herself.
The bedroom was so dark that she
couldn't see her husband.
But he didn't feel serpent-like at all.
His skin was soft,
and his voice and manner were gentle.
She asked him who he was,
but he told her this was the one question
he could never answer.
If she loved him,
she would not need to know.
His visits continued night after night.
Before long, Psyche was pregnant.
She rejoiced, but was also conflicted.
How could she raise her baby
with a man she'd never seen?
That night, Psyche approached
her sleeping husband holding an oil lamp.
What she found was the god Cupid
who sent gods and humans
lusting after each other
with the pinpricks of his arrows.
Psyche dropped her lamp,
burning Cupid with hot oil.
He said he'd been in love with Psyche
ever since his jealous mother, Venus,
asked him to embarrass the young woman
by pricking her with an arrow.
But taken with Psyche's beauty, Cupid
used the arrow on himself.
He didn't believe, however, that gods
and humans could love as equals.
Now that she knew his true form,
their hopes for happiness were dashed,
so he flew away.
Psyche was left in despair until
the unseen voice returned
and told her that it was indeed possible
for her and Cupid
to love each other as equals.
Encouraged, she set out to find him.
But Venus intercepted Psyche and said
she and Cupid could only wed
if she completed a series
of impossible tasks.
First, Psyche was told to sort a huge,
messy pile of seeds in a single night.
Just as she was abandoning hope,
an ant colony took pity on her
and helped with the work.
Successfully passing the first trial,
Psyche next had to bring Venus
the fleece of the golden sheep,
who had a reputation for
disemboweling stray adventurers,
but a river god showed her how to collect
the fleece the sheep
had snagged on briars,
and she succeeded.
Finally, Psyche had to travel
to the Underworld
and convince Proserpina,
queen of the dead,
to put a drop of her beauty in a box
for Venus.
Once again, the unseen voice came
to Psyche's aide.
It told her to bring barley cakes for
Cerberus, the guard dog to the Underworld
and coins to pay the boatman, Charon
to ferry her across the river Styx.
With her third and final task complete,
Psyche returned to the land of the living.
Just outside Venus's palace, she opened
the box of Proserpina's beauty,
hoping to keep some for herself.
But the box was filled with sleep,
not beauty,
and Psyche collapsed in the road.
Cupid, now recovered from his wounds,
flew to his sleeping bride.
He told her he'd been wrong and foolish.
Her fearlessness in the face
of the unknown
proved that she was more than his equal.
Cupid gave Psyche amborsia, the nectar
of the gods, making her immortal.
Shortly after, Psyche bore their daughter.
They named her Pleasure,
and she, Cupid, and Psyche,
whose name means soul,
have been complicating people's
love lives ever since.